okay it is a tuesday which means in my
world that it's taco tuesday but for
some people that is apparently turning
into an everyday up there yes so tell me
more about this
taco bell is testing a
subscription-style service to satisfy
the recurrent cravings the new taco
lovers pass cost between 5 and 10 bucks
depending on location and get you a
daily dose of tacos for 30 days your
options include a crunchy taco soft taco
spicy potato sauce pocket taco or
doritos locals tacos one of each for now
though the pass is available at select
locations in tucson arizona but it will
expand diana i have a quick question dan
what would you say to someone who maybe
recently spent roughly 21 at taco bell
because they just wanted it so badly
what would you say to that person is
that a curiosity
i mean look hey you just gotta give it
to the craving sometimes i love this
woman
what would you say to that i have no
idea where this person is
we were hungry heather had a bit of a
shopping spree at taco bell diane
no judgment-free zone like planet
fitness fair enough thank you diane
thanks dan have yourself a good rest of
the day thank you they just blow that up
a little bit it's okay i'm gonna blame
my husband for for most of the 21
our